today's video is sponsored by endel
so you're probably wondering how I got
here why is the bio near well known as a
functional training Advocate possibly
training using resistance machines
well it's a long story
in the fitness Community which is a term
I Don't Love by the way there's a bit of
an unfortunate tendency to think in
binaries things are either good or
they're bad this is a shame because in
reality there's very few scenarios where
something is either good or bad in most
cases you can get something positive
from nearly every trading modality every
training idea every exercise every tool
you just need to know how best to apply
it one of the best examples of this
something that's been scapegoated for an
awfully long time is the resistance
machine resistance Machines of course
being things like chest press and pec
fly machines machines where you sit down
push a pad or a handle and thereby shift
weight via a lever form of training is
coming as far as being the most
unfunctional you can be if that's a term
for completely isolating the movement
for supporting the weight so that you're
not using any of your own supporting
muscles and from just being far removed
from the way we use our strength in the
real world as we'll see in the moment I
think this is entirely missing the point
not only do I think resistance machines
have a lot of benefits for specific
groups I also think they can apply more
widely to pretty much everyone and be
used as a way to really build some
massive strength that you can't get any
other way so first let's get the obvious
things out of the way resistance
machines are really useful if you're
someone who is injured perhaps a little
bit older perhaps very new to weight if
you're worried about dropping weights on
yourself if you're worried about
tweaking Yourself by moving incorrectly
then using a resistance machine is a
really great option if you're someone
for example who's injured your legs if
you still want to train your upper body
one of the best ways to do this is by
using resistance machine what's more
though you can use resistance machines
to gently and safely rehab a injured
joint or muscle and I have first-hand
experience of this I haven't talked much
on this channel about this but I went
through a period of about two years
where I had a bad knee it hurt me when I
ran when I squatted and did all kinds of
other things and it's now completely
gone after two years of thinking this
was just going to be it from now on to
chronic pain I managed to completely get
rid of it and there are a few things
that helped with this but probably one
of the things that helped the most was
just doing really light leg extensions
it should never work for pain but if
you're able to move the injured site
gently this is a great way to get blood
flowing to encourage healing and
recovery and to strengthen the muscles
and to improve movement patterns and
that's exactly what I was able to do but
I did say that I also think resistance
machines have their place more broadly
for anybody who wants to build
impressive strength and I think they can
be one of the most effective and
Powerful tools for building max strength
those of you who watch channel regularly
will know that I'm not just interested
in building strength I'm interested in
human performance across the board and
that includes things like productivity
and cognitive performance and for that
endel today's sponsor is an absolutely
fantastic tool so Wendell is an app and
what it does is it creates personalized
atmospheric soundscapes that can react
to inputs like location weather even
your heart rate if you have a compatible
smart watch this one's really cool
because it actually uses gyroscopes to
respond to the way you're moving it's
called move
these Landscapes can fit a variety of
scenarios they're perfect if you're
trying to be productive but you can also
listen to them when you're unwinding
meditating or trying to Drift Off to
Sleep the app is based on no
neuroscience and it's been shown to
boost productivity more efficiently than
listening to your Spotify playlist for
instance on top of that there are
special content Partnerships with a
range of cool and original artists the
app has these really nice visualizations
as well which I actually find Aid with
that productive mindset if you want to
check it out yourself then the first 100
people to download envelope at the link
below will get a free week of audio
experiences thank you once again to
endel for sponsoring today's video and
now on with the show
but I did say that I also think
resistance machines have their place
more broadly for anybody who wants to
build impressive strength and I think
they can be one of the most effective
and Powerful tools for building max
strength the obvious reason for this is
that you can safely pile on a huge
amount of weight you can challenge
yourself to lift something you wouldn't
be able to do without a very good
Spotter and even then it's a little bit
you know hairy I used to do crazy bench
presses with my friend who'd spot me but
these days I don't necessarily have
someone strong enough to stand behind me
and I know that they're going to be able
to lift that 150 kilograms off of me if
I get trapped underneath in fact I
usually train alone and I don't
particularly like asking strangers to
help spot me so I avoid my one rep max
and I avoid my two rep max and my three
rep max and instead I do things I can do
for maybe four repetitions and then I
usually stop short of complete failure
because obviously I don't get pinned
underneath that's extremely embarrassing
and it can also strangle you even worse
for something like the squat or the
deadlift where you risk injuring your
back or getting trapped you know
underneath at the bottom of the squat
there are things you can do with pins
but there's still that element of risk
you can even just twist your body tip
the weight find it's a little bit
unbalanced conversely if you're on a
chest press if you're on a leg press or
something like that you can put as much
weight as you like on there if you can't
lift it no problem also not that
embarrassing because no one can really
see what you're doing and if you do get
stuck you can just drop it it'll make a
loud crash but it won't go anywhere and
it's not going to hurt anyone far far
safer this means you can not only train
with your one rep max but you can really
push and push and go beyond that and
this is important because when you lift
a one rep maximum you actually aren't
performing a one rep max very long at
all the one at Max as an exercise takes
you know a few seconds but even within
those few seconds only a very small
portion of that is truly your maximum
effort because of the strength curve
because of the leverage because of joint
angles because of momentum so for
example there's going to be a sticking
point in the squat for many people it's
down the bottom that's the hardest part
for them so that's the only point at
which they're providing their maximum
effort so we're talking a fraction of a
second and you can't go higher than that
you can use things like accommodating
resistance etc etc and that's obviously
an option but even then it's not precise
science conversely you can load your one
rep max and you can hold that sticking
point you can try and fight it and then
as soon as you're done you can lower the
weight slightly and go again so that you
really are providing your maximum effort
for a much longer duration of time and
this is important because not only are
you causing maximum muscle damage for
potential growth but also training that
neural Drive the ability to engage that
maximum strength and this is what's
really key here so by doing that you're
teaching your body to recruit more motor
units and thereby tap into more of the
strength that you already have old time
strong men and strong men in general use
things like overcoming isometrics to
teach themselves to tap into even more
of that strength and you do this by
teaching yourself to try and recruit
maximum Force so by loading yourself up
massively on these things and just
struggling under them in a way that
wouldn't be safe under a freeway 8 you
can build much more strength and power
and you can even use resistance machines
in this way as a form of overcoming
isometric whether you're getting to that
point and then pushing against it making
it kind of more natural yielding
isometric but where you're doing your
maximum maximum effort or you can
literally just pile up the weight much
higher than you can press and push
against it or if you're more interested
in hypertrophy strength endurance and
max strength combining those things you
can do crazy drop sets using resistance
machines so what I'll often like to do
is I'll use the chest press for example
I'll attempt my one rep maximum then
I'll drop the weight slightly and do two
or three reps drop the weight slightly
and do 10 reps drop the rate slightly
and do a flush set until I'm completely
burned out and that way not only am I
training my maximum strength not only am
I training muscle fiber recruitment I'm
also training strength endurance I'm
also getting metabolic stress loads of
muscle damage fantastic for building a
lot of size so if you're interested in
the hypertrophy this is a fantastic tool
too and especially because it's isolated
in this case so bodybuilders can get a
lot of use out of these machines of
course because they allow them to
isolate specific muscle Souls and at the
end of the day the strength you build on
Resistance machines is going to have
some transfer some carry over into those
other movements if you can chest press a
huge amount of weight then you will be
able to bench press more than you could
otherwise yeah you won't have that
balance or that feel for it maybe the
grip and if you do also train the bench
press then you are going to be able to
bring that strength over and apply it
building that mule drive through the
kind of overcoming isometric methods you
might see that this can translate to
better more powerful lifts and this is
where I struggle a little bit to
understand a lot of people's reasoning
because the people who say that all you
need are those big three lifts you know
bench press squats and deadlift will
also look down their nose at resistance
machines as I've said in the past the
bench press has actually applied to very
much in the real world because when you
lie on the ground and then press
something over the head you might have
that pushing strength but if you fly
backwards because you're not that heavy
well then it's not going to be all that
much use now especially if you're you
know arching your back puffing your
chest out and retracting your shoulder
blades who pushes like that nobody this
is not a practical exercise directly
and with the deadlift that's probably
the most function of the big three lifts
but even then you don't pick things up
in a direct line using perfect form
using a perfectly straight bar we pick
things up whilst twisting we pick things
up whilst moving and so we need more
variation if we want to cover every
single aspect of our movement
this is why I think it's important to do
things like twisting and moving in the
frontal plane so don't say that you
can't get any benefit from resistance
machines because the benefit you get
from resistance machines is just one
step back from the benefit that you
would get from those big three lifts no
movement perfectly matches everything
that you're going to do but by doing a
wide range of things we get a lot of
those different benefits and we combine
them in a useful way we learn the
movement patterns we train the
supporting muscles then we build the
prime movers in a big powerful way
and as for that neural drive that you
can build by doing this and as for those
massive drop sets yeah they're just
they're game changing they'll build a
huge amount of strength so don't turn
your nose up at resistance machines
they're actually awesome
and that's all I want to say on the
matter be really interested to hear what
your thoughts on this are these
resistance machines why not do you think
that I'm talking baloney and how do you
integrate it into your training I'd love
to know your thoughts
if you're looking for a training program
that actually doesn't really use
resistance machines but does use
overcoming isometrics as well as
bodybuilding and powerlifting techniques
combined with kettlebells calisthenics
Mobility training even brain training
and you might like my ebook and training
program super functional training 2.0
you'll find a link to that in
description down below
comes with an 80 Page Plus ebook and
over two hours of instructional video so
yeah check it out either way thank you
so much for watching this one guys and
I'll see you next time
bye for now